scuffles at Australia's University of
Queensland in July when pro-beijing
demonstrators disrupted a rally in
support of the Hong Kong protests video
posted on social media showed the two
sides hurling abuse at each other while
the Chinese National Anthem blasted from
a speaker
[Music]
it was not an isolated incident on a
campus where about 17% of students come
from China
protesters critical of Beijing's
policies are frequently confronted by
Chinese Communist Party loyalists it's a
situation echoed in other international
universities with large Chinese student
bodies at the University of Auckland in
New Zealand a video posted on YouTube
showed a heated exchange between Pro
Hong Kong demonstrators and supporters
of China from China Lenin wall at the
college and others around the world have
been vandalized multiple times the walls
made up of messages of support have been
a key feature of the Hong Kong protests
at Simon Fraser University in Canada a
man was filmed ripping down the notes
its tactics like these that have raised
concerns because they could threaten
freedom of speech on campus
protesters also say they have been
intimidated and threatened after taking
part in student rallies against China
with much of the abuse happening on
Chinese social media platforms like
WeChat or Y Bo Adila yard Muhammad is a
student at the University of Adelaide in
Australia and has been at a number of
these demonstrations where Pro and anti
China students have faced off against
each other I began by asking her how
these interactions have generally been
some of the protests there it does it is
quite simple at the others they do get a
bit heated so on one side you have the
prey Hong Kong is chanting or having a
couple of speeches and on the other side
you have the pro Chinese protesters
singing the Chinese national anthem also
chanting slogans a lot of these protests
they are open mic and we do allow the
pro Chinese students to come and speak
if they want to when those who do speak
are quite civilized they do try to
they're quite civilized and they try to
ask ask what our experiences are but
they're also quite um close-minded and
they don't want to understand they ask
to understand that I also don't want to
so they do get a bit confusing so seeing
them in the perspective of the pro pro
Chinese students there have been
allegations and there have been reports
in the media that perhaps there is some
state backing for a lot of the pro China
students do you agree with that do you
find that do you think that do you see
on campus that potentially there could
be some backing from certain quarters
for these Pro China students I do
believe that there may be some sort of
financial backing our support from the
Chinese government towards these
students however as I haven't seen it
firsthand
in regards to the students here in
Adelaide I do believe we had the student
politics elections a couple weeks ago
and we had a group called international
voice which was majority
students international international
Chinese students that were report
afterwards that those students were
telling other Chinese students that if
they didn't support them if they didn't
vote for them that they would eventually
they would be deported back to China so
there were these kind of threats that
may be linked towards the government
system but they're not quite proven
they're having other instances with
other process in the last couple of the
years where Chinese communities Chinese
families and Chinese international
students have come out supporting
perhaps Chinese official member coming
to Australia where we are protesting
against his arrival have been supported
by the Chinese consulate student Adila
yar Muhammad there
let's bring in Alex Yazzie from the
Australian capital Canberra now alex is
an analyst at the australian strategic
policy institute and he has done a lot
of research on alleged chinese
interference in australia Alex good to
have you on the program can I just ask
you at the outset does it look like the
Chinese state is orchestrating or
supporting students who are protesting
on Australian university campuses thank
you at the very least we know that the
Chinese government is encouraging these
kinds of activities the consulate has
released statements encouraging students
to show their patriotism and protect
China's sovereignty and there's a lot of
evidence that groups linked to the
Chinese government are involved in
orchestrating some of these protests the
Australian government has set up a task
force to look at Chinese interference in
Australian university campuses how is
that task force going to proceed what
are the things they're going to be
looking at they're gonna be looking at a
whole range of areas including cyber
research collaboration freedom of speech
and and some of these issues around what
the Chinese Communist Party is trying to
do to influence students and discuss
Shinzon university campuses so it'll be
a forum that brings together the
Australian government with university
officials hopefully to deal with these
issues but Alex why is it so easy for
the Chinese embassy or for the Chinese
government to be able to encourage and
support these protests on Australian
university campuses surely there must be
something that the Australian Government
can do well for a long time the
Australian government and universities
have really turned a blind eye to a lot
of the work that the Chinese government
does on our university campuses to build
influence networks and to be able to
mobilize Chinese students and and in
fact there are very few levers that the
government currently has to deal with
this issue there are simply there's
simply such a large number of
organisations linked to the Chinese
government operating on our campuses to
influence politics influence discussions
and protect the interests of the Chinese
Communist Party so how effective will
this task force really be that the
government has appointed I think it'll
be effective in getting the universities
themselves to do more because ultimately
the real burden should be on our
universities to do more to integrate
Chinese students to protect them from
surveillance and intimidation by the
Chinese Communist Party and it's only by
getting universities on board that I
think the government can deal with these
issues the alternate argument of course
here would be that Chinese students or
if you call them pro-beijing students
they have an equal right to protest and
to voice their opinions on Australian
universities and that should not be seen
as interference would that be fair to
say I think I think that is very fair I
think in Australia as a free and
democratic society we do tolerate voices
from all kinds of perspectives but the
difference and part of the concern here
is that the Chinese government does seem
to be having a role in some of these
activities so rather than being genuine
expressions of political or patriotic
sentiments these are activities
facilitated by the Chinese government
and also through also facilitated by the
propaganda bubble that it is Corin
overseas through platform
like the social media app WeChat Alex
Yosuke from the Australian strategic
policy institute thank you very much for
that thank you